seit fünf jahren gewährt in ecuador asyl
in seiner londoner botschaft jetzt ist
wikileaks gründer julien assange von dem
südamerikanischen land eingebürgert
worden
den antrag aus quito dem 46 jährigen an
den diplomatenstatus und damit immunität
zu gewähren lehnte london ab 2012 hatte
sich assange in die diplomatische
vertretung geflüchtet aus angst vor
strafverfolgung wegen der
wikileaks-enthüllungen assange
befürchtet in schweden und von dort aus
in die usa ausgeliefert zu werden wo ihm
ein prozess wegen geheimnisverrats droht
die schwedische justiz hat ihre
ermittlungen gegen assange wegen
vergewaltigungs vorwürfen jedoch
inzwischen eingestellt damit wurde auch
ein europäischer haftbefehl hinfällig
bei einem verlassen der botschaft brot
assange dennoch die festnahme durch die
britische polizei wegen verletzung von
bewährungsauflagen